[Music]
this week on booknotes our guest is
historian howard zinn he joins us to
discuss his recent book a people's
history of the united states
1492 to present
howard zinn when did you first start
thinking about writing a people's
history of the united states
um
well i think you know somewhere in the
70s
um
and i was teaching and
people kept asking me to recommend sort
of one volume history of the united
states
written from a point of view that would
reflect the sensibilities of the 60s you
know that of the movements of the civil
rights movement and the anti-war
and uh
i couldn't find a book that would do it
i think that's what happens very often
if you can't find a book that does what
you want you write it
so
um
but i had to wait until the war in
vietnam ended
because
until then i was so wrapped up in the
movement against the war and my writing
was wrapped up in it
now i wrote a book about vietnam vietnam
the logical withdrawal i wrote a book
about civil disobedience i wrote
another book on sort of the politics of
history
but my my writings were all geared to
sort of immediate
political necessities and i didn't have
the leisure to sit down and do
what i sort of had in the back of my
mind and then after the war
i i
well my agent prodded me my wife prodded
me my wife was a big prod you know
because i started
and then i i i try to give up a few
times because it's too daunting a job i
mean the whole thing
from the beginning no too much but my
wife said you have to do it so i did it
so
so i began writing yeah in the
uh
late 70s i actually went to paris in 78
to teach
and i had this romantic idea you know
about going to paris and writing you
know
i spent four months in paris
easy teaching you know one
day a week plenty of time to write
didn't write a word
because it was paris
got in the way
but when i came back
i immediately got to work and and i
think that's where i work i said well
then i worked furiously day and night
and uh
my
my
editor at harper and at that time was
harper and rome my editor hugh van duzen
was very encouraging and harper was was
terrific
they didn't edit what i said i mean this
sounds bad
[Laughter]
when i say they didn't edit i mean they
didn't change what i wrote you know they
didn't say no you've got to do this
you've got to add this you've got to
take this out i sent it to them and my
then editor a woman named cynthia murman
who's working with hugh van dijken said
and i was expecting some big thing from
her with 97 pages of notes and she sent
back sort of one line
saying this is wonderful
every author loves that
so and the first edition was 1980 first
edition the 1980 they published
5 000 hardback copies
now
they didn't know what would happen to it
neither did i
they
5000 hardback copies immediately went to
paperback
and then every year the sales went up up
up
and uh my uh
my editor at harper hughes and said
we had lunch one day in new york you
know those publishers lunches
the publisher pays
for a nice restaurant and uh
and he said uh
so this is unusual he said you know
usually books even books that sell very
well they sell for one or two years and
then it goes down so this book goes up
up every year and that's the way it's
been for 20 years in 20 years how many
books do you think you sold
oh well as of
let's see where are we
as of last june that it sold over 600
000
by now it must be getting close to 700
000. i know it sold more in 99 than it
sold in 98 and more 98 than the 97 so
it's uh
you know it's
so it surprised me now how does a man
who writes a history yeah which
basically is uh and you can explain
exactly what it is i mean it's not
basically your capitalist rah-rah
history book
basically become somewhat of a rich man
from the book
are you saying i'm a rich fan because
you're looking at the way i'm dressed
but if you tile up
700 000 copies that's true it's true i
mean it's i'm in awe of the money i've
made from the book although if you're
divided by 20 years
right
you know if you divide
i don't know 600 000 or 700 000 by 20
years then it comes out to like 35 000 a
year and then if you add that to my
meager professor's salary then i'm sort
of doing okay
well in let's put this way you know
enough to
you know buy half a house
and buy half a house on cape cod you
know with with friends and and uh
buy a new automobile instead of a used
automobile
and uh that's nice uh
but of course i didn't expect i didn't
write the book thinking i would make a
lot of money and i didn't write it to
make a lot of money and i wrote it and
the reason my wife was urging me to
write it is just she thought it was
needed and i guess i didn't myself gauge
the extent to which it was needed i
think the reason it has sold i mean
harper didn't go in a big advertising
campaign they didn't put ads in the new
york times or i mean they distributed
the book very well
you know their big outfit and they get
the book around but i think it was word
of mouth and i think fundamentally
the book just met a need
that people had after the movements of
the 60s
people began to rethink
all sorts of issues black history
women's history
labor movement
war and anti-war movements and the
traditional textbooks and the
traditional books on american history
didn't satisfy them
so they wanted to i think they were
looking for this point of view let me
just ask you about some people uh that
you write about in the book and just
give a real brief synopsis of what you
think of them so people watching have
never maybe never heard of this but
haven't understand where you're coming
from christopher columbus
christopher columbus i have to laugh
because
that was the most explosive thing
in the book uh
that is
when i began getting letters from all
over the country my first chapter deals
with christopher columbus
and when i began getting letters from
all over the country
about the book
a disproportionate number of them were
about christopher columbus and the
reason is
that i think although there are a lot of
things in the book that people never
heard of and a lot of new angles in the
book that people
never saw but i think what i said about
christopher columbus was the most
startling was every american
has learned about christopher columbus
you know and from elementary school on
christopher columbus the great
adventurer navigator you know
brave man religious uh a hero well there
are all these cities named after
columbus and all the statues in columbus
they
so then when i said that
you know yes for sure columbus was a
great navigator was a brave man
but he was also you might say the first
ruthless imperialist of you know the and
uh i mean he kidnapped indians
he was greedy for gold
to satisfy his financiers back in spain
and in search of gold
he
drove the indians
mutilated them when they didn't bring
them gold
kidnapped them and bring brought them
back to spain because he had to have
something to show his
his uh
supporters back in spain
and and essentially
began a campaign which
resulted in the genocide of the
indigenous people of hispaniola the
island where he and the spaniards did a
lot of you know their marauding the
island which is now haiti and the
dominican republic
so this uh this picture of columbus was
a very startling one in fact i must tell
you this there was a i got a letter from
a teacher high school teacher in
california she was using my book
well she was using my book as a
supplement to the regular text because
there was a time i think it's not so
true now there was a time when using my
book
was just not accepted and especially in
high schools where there's a more rigid
control of textbooks but she was using
my book
the way it was used very often teachers
would photocopy chapters and it sounded
like sami's dot like you know the
underground photocopy chapters and hand
it out to the class
well but the student brought
the chapter in columbus back home her
mother
looked at it and went into a fit
and asked for an investigation of the
teacher
because you know this was just
outrageous to her that anybody should
say these things about columbus let me
jump all the way to the present okay
bill clinton ah bill clinton
yeah actually uh um yeah the book does
go up to bill clinton yeah i brought it
up as close to the president i can't
and i guess what i say about bill
clinton
you know i'm not interested in the sex
scandals or anything like that
i'm interested in his policies i'm
interested in this domestic policy and
foreign policy and what i said about
bill clinton is that he fits in
to what richard hofstadter you know one
of the great american historians of this
century what richard hofstede called the
american political tradition
and when hofstadter wrote his book the
american political tradition what he was
saying was that
oh sure there are democrats and
republicans liberals and conservatives
and they occupy the white house in turn
but fundamentally even though there are
differences among them the certain
fundamental things they have in common
one of them is nationalism and a
willingness to go to war
and the other is capitalism and the
market and
private
enterprise and and i think
hofstadter was right and clinton fits in
i mean he's as
nationalistic
as ready to go to war he doesn't cut the
military budget he increases the
military budget
he does what
republicans and democrats before him
have done
and that is try to extend american
military and political and economic
power as far over the world as he can
and domestically
while his domestic policies are probably
maybe a little bit
more progressive than the republicans
fundamentally he doesn't
make any serious changes in the social
structure he doesn't do away with
poverty doesn't do away with
uninsured you know
people people who don't have medical
insurance
he doesn't use the
uh the huge wealth that we have
to
take care of the 30 40 million people in
this country
who live like third world people
and
so
no he
he's a very good salesman go back to
george washington
washington i mean washington uh
admirable you know in many ways of
course
yeah a great leader and a great military
leader
but my emphasis in this book
is not on the founding fathers you know
when i deal with that early period the
revolutionary period
i treat the founding fathers as what i
think they are and that is
the american elite
who want independence from england which
is a good thing uh because england has
been an oppressive force
but they want independence from england
of
mostly for their own purposes that is to
replace the british elite with an
american elite
when they set up the new government when
they set up the constitution i mean they
set up
a strong central government which will
be able to legislate on behalf of
bondholders and slave holders and
manufacturers
and western land speculators
i mean charles beard in his book an
economic interpretation of the
constitution or which he wrote back in
1913 which
startled people because he
sort of
was not reverential towards the founding
fathers and he said look these were guys
with economic interests uh sure they
were very smart much smarter than the
people we have around today
much more eloquent than the people we
have around today you know madison adams
i mean you have to admire
their elegance of language their
brilliance of mind their you know
wide education
but in fact they
they
set up a government that was designed to
maintain control and prevent rebellion
by poor people after all the
constitutional convention was convened
just after shea's rebellion in western
massachusetts shea's rebellion had a lot
to do with the convening of the
constitutional convention because he was
a he was an uprising of farmers
led by revolutionary war veterans who
had land in western massachusetts and
suddenly found that the promises made to
them in the revolution you know it's a
war for democracy for liberty for us and
so on and it didn't seem to work out
because they were being harassed by the
people who controlled the legislature in
massachusetts they're being taxed they
couldn't afford it land was being taken
away from them their farms were being
taken away livestock taken away they
rebelled under the leadership of former
captain daniel shays
and
i mean it's quite a rebellion i mean
they stormed the courthouses wouldn't
let auctions take place sometimes they
were joined by the local militia who
were called out to suppress them and
then joined them because they saw them
in a righteous cause
and
shane's rebellion was put down but it
put a scare into the founding fathers
let me come all the way back the other
way again okay ask you about ronald
reagan
ronald reagan
uh well
um
you know what happens when the president
leaves office uh
no matter what his policies were in
office a glow
a soft glow descends upon him and he
he uh
you forget what he did
uh and you look kind of kindly on him
especially on reagan because he was
such a nice you know good humored
avuncular person
but in fact
reagan
you know represented really i think as
both parties have with the republican
party somewhat more than the democratic
party he represented the wealthy
interests of the country
and he
uh
know the tax structure changed in such a
way as to benefit the the upper one
percent of the population and then of
course in foreign policy you know he was
so obsessed with
the soviet communism and soviet
expansion that he saw everything that
happened everywhere in the world as the
work of the soviets so the revolution in
nicaragua
you know in 1979 that overthrow was a
very corrupt government which the united
states had supported the samoa
government as a revolution it was quite
a popular revolution in nicaragua and
reagan determined to put it down and so
he secretly and finally illegally gets
arms sets up the contras whom he called
freedom fighters
and they go on rampages and they commit
a lot of atrocities
and he he supported the military
dictatorship of el salvador again fear
of rebellion i mean latin america has
always seen attempts at popular
rebellion against dictatorships and in
our time since the cold war with the
soviet union all of these popular
uprisings have been interpreted as
you know attempts of the soviet union to
spread its power when actually
represented indigenous movements trying
to get rid of dictatorships and trying
to get land for peasants and so on
but the result was we kept the reagan
administration kept giving money and
supporting
really the death squads in el salvador
and terrible terrible things happen
how long have you been a teacher
well i started teaching
my first real teaching job was at
spelman college in atlanta georgia
black women's college and i went there
in 1956
[Music]
uh taught there for seven years until
1963.
where did you come from to there well
columbia i i was i lived in new york my
wife and i lived in a low-income housing
project in new york lillian walder
houses
and uh we both had two little kids
working
both of us working
both was working my way through graduate
school and i was getting my phd at
columbia won this job
at the spelman college opened up and i
became suddenly chair
of this tiny department a
prestigious thing like being a head
waiter of a two-waiter restaurant you
know about four people in the department
but it was a
very
fortunate time for me because i was
coming into the south when the civil
rights movement was beginning to develop
and i was there to see it
spread and and
work its way into a great tumultuous
movement and to become part of that and
become involved in it your wife's name
is roslyn yeah and where did you meet
her
oh i met her in
brooklyn we both
were brought up in in sort of a
working-class neighborhood of brooklyn
and uh what was the neighborhood
it was williamsburg or sort of on the
edge between williamsburg and bedford
stuyvesant but
it uh
and
her father ran a little gas station my
father was a waiter
and i was working in the shipyard at the
age of 18 i went to work work in the
brooklyn navy yard and i worked there
for three years and while i was there as
a shipyard worker i met her
and
and we just had a few dates and then i
enlisted in the air force
and then we carried on a long
correspondence while i was off training
and
all over the country and i came back
finally from bombing school and gunnery
school and i had lieutenant swings and
and came back to
brooklyn
and four days later we got married
now
what was your did you have strong
political beliefs when you were in the
service
well my political beliefs developed from
about the age of 18 on when i was
working in the shipyard or berkeley in
the brooklyn navy yard
because i was i encountered this little
group of well about three or four guys
who were
like me young workers and and we were
shut out of the trade unions because the
afl
was craft union and all the unskilled
workers were shut out of it so most of
the shipyard workers were not even
unionized
and we decided to form our own union and
these other guys and and we would get
together and we would read radical
literature marx
up in sinclair uh jack london
uh and uh
it was i suppose it's fair to say it was
sort of
i got a kind of marxist education
while i was working in a shipyard so by
the time i enlisted in the air force i
was all imbued with war against fascism
and i i volunteered and
uh
and
and in the air force i i maintain you
know i maintain these kind of political
views except that
so towards the end of my air force days
i was in england flying the last bombing
missions of the war
uh i began to
become disillusioned with the soviet
union which a lot of people on the left
you know had looked to
as you know the great socialist hope and
i began reading and learning and and
became very disillusioned with the
soviet union but i remember i still
consider myself a socialist
to this day
to this day
to at least yesterday
but but the um
in your book you say that uh
world war ii and the bombing of pearl
harbor was played up as a big shock
and that's what it's portrayed as in
history but you say it wasn't a shock at
all no i mean the evidence is clear that
the united states government expected
the japanese to strike because
the tensions between the united states
and japan had been building up building
up building up
and and we had been tightening the
pincers on japan more and more and you
know finally cut off oil supplies and
and it was we we knew that and and we
had broken the japanese code you know we
knew the japanese were going to
to attack somewhere
but although some people think that the
roosevelt administration knew they were
going to attack pearl harbor i'm not at
all sure of this
but it was known that there would be a
japanese attack maybe it was expected
they would attack hawaii
later
after attacking the philippines and
moving you know their way
up but
so it was a half surprise
when how many years did you actually
serve in the military well two and a
half years in the air force did you drop
a lot of bombs
well i dropped yeah i dropped a fair a
number of bombs on as i said it was the
last missions of the war and i dropped
bombs on berlin i dropped bombs on
pilsen czechoslovakia on
places in hungary and
and
towards the
right and just before the end of the war
i i participated in the bombing mission
that was going to have a very important
effect on my thinking
and that was a bombing mission in which
we bombed a little french town on the
atlantic coast
called ryan
we thought we were through bombing we
thought our missions were over
everybody knew the war would end in a
few weeks you know the russians and the
americans that joined on the elba france
was long overrun
and they woke us up one morning at one
o'clock one o'clock in the morning the
usual wake up time for a mission were
you in england we were in england in
east anglia and uh
and uh well and um
you can take off at six but it wake you
up at one
uh
and and told us we're gonna bomb this
little town in france which was
you know
what are we doing bombing a town in
france but interestingly enough and it
tells you something about the military
mentality the military training nobody
would dare stand up in the briefing room
and ask why are we bombing this little
town
when the war is going to be over
why are we going to kill more people
yeah and
nobody asked that question but they
briefed us said well there are several
thousand german troops hanging around
this little town they're waiting for the
war to end they're not doing anything
but we're going to destroy them
and then they said something which gave
me a clue later when i thought about it
to why we went on this mission they said
we're not going to use regular
demolition bombs we have something new
uh we will you're going to instead of
dropping the usual 12 500 pound
demolition bombs you're going to drop 30
100 pound canisters of gel jellied
gasoline it was napalm the first use of
napalm
in the european theater
now but it wasn't called napalm then so
we have we really didn't know
and again you know the military my i to
this day
you know
i understand very well how soldiers
commit atrocities
how airmen bomb civilians
how terrible things are done in war
because you're trained to do your job
to follow orders not to ask questions
and here we are officers we're supposed
to sort of have a little more initiative
but it's not true
you know in fact you might say you know
the fact that you're an officer means
you've had even more intensive training
so we went over and bombed dry on and
destroyed the town
killed the germans and also killed the
frenchmen
and
women and children in royal
and it didn't
the thing is you'd bomb from 30 000 feet
you don't see
what's happening down there
you don't see people suffering you don't
see people
burning you don't see limbs
falling you
uh you just see little flashes in the in
the in the dark you know and and you go
back and you're debriefed and
uh you don't think about it as
horrifying later
only later did i begin to think about it
and i was horrified by what i had done
then i'm still horrified by what i did
but i think that had an effect on my
thinking about war because here i was in
the best of wars and i believed it was
the best wars because i volunteered for
it war against fascism i mean how could
you find a more bestial enemy
and yet it sort of
it complicated the war for me it
complicated the morality of the war and
it made me begin to think that war
itself
is evil even when it starts with a good
cause even when the enemy is horrible
that there's something about war
especially in our time when war
inevitably involves indiscriminate
killing
and i came to the conclusion that war
simply cannot be accepted morally as a
solution for whatever problems are in
the world whatever tyranny whatever
borders across
whatever problems there are somehow
human ingenuity has to find a way to
deal with that
without the indiscriminate killing that
war involves what would you have done
had you been president and those bombs
were dropped on pearl harbor
that's the toughest question i've ever
faced i was i knew you would ask tough
questions
[Laughter]
but um
you know by then it was too late you
know
uh
but
uh
what do we do then
you know
three i say is a tough question
people have asked me the question what
would you have done about germany about
they've asked me the general question
nobody you're the first one in all these
years it was asked me this very specific
question what would you do if you were
president on the day pearl harbor was
attacked
why would you have done that
and you know
of course with my with with the
psychology i had then as a volunteer in
the air force and so on i said well of
course we're at war now we've got to do
all the things that war requires and so
on and so forth
and now
i think
well
um
what is the alternative
to simply going on an all-out war
which is going to result in enormous
number of casualties is there any way
of dealing with japanese aggression
in
a way that is unique in world history i
mean this is really i mean it's it's
very hard for people to think this way
because once
once a historical event has taken place
a certain way
it is very hard to go back and imagine a
different sequence of events and once we
have gone through world war ii and and
won the war and after dropping
all those bombs and so on we can't
imagine there could be another scenario
and uh
and i confess i i i haven't worked out
an alternative scenario well let me jump
way beyond that to
saddam hussein going into kuwait oh yes
what would you have done there oh well
no there there i think it's the answers
is clearer
i would not go to war over kuwait
uh
because and this is what happened
because the number of people killed in
the war and the the the things that
happen as a result of the war
far overshadow even what saddam hussein
did to kuwait
but
in every case
i would always look for
solutions short of war in the case of
kuwait i would look for diplomatic
solutions and they were the american
press didn't play these up at all and so
the american public did not know about
them
but there were possibilities for
diplomatic solutions there were
saddam hussein was willing to give up
kuwait if he could get other things
which were connected with oil and the
price of oil and access to oil things
which the united states did not want to
give up
and uh
and there were there were overtures made
uh before the
uh after saddam hussein
invaded kuwait and before the united
states began the war and the united
states simply ignored them
when um
you know the secretary of state james
baker was sent
to meet um
asia's the foreign minister
of iraq
uh before the war started
his instructions were
do not negotiate
i remember that very clearly i thought
this was very strange why are they
meeting
if there's not going to be any
compromise negotiations some way of
getting saddam hussein out of kuwait
giving some concessions but not having a
war but no no negotiations in other
words only an ultimatum you get out of
kuwait with no conditions well if you
if you want to avoid war
if you want to minimize casualties you
have to be willing to compromise even
with evil people
and uh
i mean we would have had to do that with
japan if we didn't want to drop the
bombs on hiroshima and nagasaki
that is we could have compromised what
was opposition
you know unconditional surrender we
could have said okay there's a condition
we'll meet we'll take care of the
emperor we won't bother the emperor and
we wouldn't have had to drop the bombs
let me go back to uh
spelman okay seven years at spelman yes
where did you go after that
i went to boston university
still there
well i'm still sort of that is
you asked me how long i was teaching
well
seven years at spelman 24 years at
boston university but i stopped teaching
in
88 10 years ago about 10 years ago i
stopped teaching 11 years ago
but i taught that for 24 years i'm now a
professor emeritus
my daughter asked me what is a professor
emeritus and i said it means you're
unemployed
you have two kids two kids
girls two girls no we our adult we have
a daughter and a son
and uh yeah
they're married they have kids and and
yeah what do they do what do they do
a daughter
was was a nurse
and
she's active in local environmental
things she and her husband john kabadzin
who is a
sort of
fairly well known in sort of behavioral
science and meditation they've written a
book together on parenting
and they live in lexington mass and they
have they have three wonderful kids and
he took her name and
yeah they well they hyphenated their
names
which created a problem for our
grandson
because at one point our grandson who is
now in his 20s had a girlfriend and i i
and i asked him well well uh how are
things going with your girlfriend he
said it can't be serious she has a
hyphenated name
so if you had four shoes you can't have
two eyes
so anyway
our our son is a theater person on cape
cod he runs with he and his
uh co-producer
our son jefferson uh and his co-producer
gear poppy they run the little theater
in wellfleet on cape cod and they've
been doing it for many years and
they're the kind of heroic theater
people
that uh
you you hear about you know they they
uh struggle struggle struggle to put on
plays that they care about each year and
he's married has two little ones
uh about five and
five yeah five and two and
uh
two different generations of
grandchildren our daughter married young
our son married late and so we have a
grandson who's 24 and we have a grand
and another grandson who's two
i don't know how many years ago but we
do call-in shows here at this network um
and callers would call up ever so often
and
say why don't you have on
noam chomsky
michael parente
and howard zen oh
really and it's kind of a you know i got
the sense there must be a cult up
it's a conspiracy no it's just going on
for years that those those three names
are joined together oh really okay
people who have never heard of noam
chomsky and michael pereini and howard
zane why would they join the tree again
well i think the three of us had joined
probably be the three of us although we
probably have some differences here and
there but the three of us are all sort
of radical social critics
critics of american foreign policy
critical critics of domestic policy
and the three of us have written a fair
amount and so
we're sort of known in progressive left
radical circles of course noam chemsky
is known far beyond that
um
and uh and i think they ask that because
they're very conscious of the fact that
the three of us
are not invited
to be on major network
interviews you know and
forums
and uh you know if you look at uh
valero report you know i mean they have
all sorts of experts and congressmen and
secretaries of state discussing
but you will
almost never i think he was once on
there i mean owen chomsky is and i say
this not because he's a friend of mine
or because we have very similar
political views
he just
is a brilliant brilliant guy
who knows
more about american foreign policy
maybe than anybody in the country
and uh
and the idea that there are all these
panels that you see on tv and that you
never see him on
suggest to people that there's a kind of
yeah censorship it's not a censorship
that comes from the government but a
kind of self-censorship of networks and
programs and
that want to play it safe are you ever
called by any of these programs
um
not no
well let's see the closest i'm trying to
think the closest i came was
during the the
war on kosovo
i was called by
cnbc
which i guess is a pretty big thing and
that's the closest i've come to
you know being on a kind of network
program discussing some important issues
i've been
on national public radio you know a
couple of times but most of the time
my
talks are carried on alternative radio
programs little community radio stations
sometimes i'm interviewed by radio
stations
in new york
w and pacifica radio
uh
i don't know where c-span fits in maybe
this is the closest i've come to
something big
well tell me about i mean this book sold
seven hundred thousand copies as you
know
most books don't come close to selling
700 yeah yeah 700 000 copies or whatever
what is it you think about your book
that
grabs
people's attention and who buys it
i think what grabs people's attention
about the book is that they
are startled by the point of view
uh
they
see
uh historical events that they have
learned about like columbus the american
revolution the civil war world war one
they see
events that they've heard about but they
see these looked at from very different
points of view they say columbus looked
at from the point of view of indians as
they say the revolution looked at from
the point of view of soldiers who mutiny
against george washington
uh you know they see that
not the age of jackson seen through the
white house but they say the age of
jackson through the eyes of the
indians in south
east united states
who jackson sends the army to drive out
of their homes you know they see the
american industrial revolution from the
standpoint of working people and farmers
people go on strike
they don't see military heroes they see
the heroes of the book being people who
protest against war
they don't see world war one through
woodrow wilson they
see helen keller
who
again they see people that they heard
about and they they get a different
slant i mean you every school kid learns
about helen keller this wonderful woman
who overcame you know blindness and
other handicaps but they never learned
that she was a socialist or that she
campaigned against world war one
and
so they learn about people in this book
that just don't appear and and they
learn about events the ludlow massacre
the colorado coal strike the textile
stripe some of the most dramatic events
in american history ignored in the
regular textbooks and so
you know
last night i got a call i mean you ask
who reads the book last night i got a
call
he said remember me i used to mow your
lawn he said then i went out to johns
hopkins
and i said yeah i was wondering does he
really
want to mow our lord again now he's been
to johns hopkins no
he said i just want to tell you i just i
didn't know you were a writer and i just
picked up your people's history and he
says it just blew my mind
and that's the reaction and
this morning as i was getting ready to
go in the car picked me up to take me to
the airport to bring me here the phone
rang and my wife answered and as i was
walking out the door she said uh this
was some man who just read your book and
he said this is the best book he's ever
read
and
so i i've gotten a huge amount i mean
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
letters from all over the country i'm
going to answer
your question who reads the book
um
let me restate the question
do schools buy it or do individuals buy
it both
well
schools for a long time are reluctant to
buy it
and i don't know what the percentage is
that is how now more high schools
are willing to buy it officially now
um at one time they will not
uh college teachers would use it but i
think most of its sales just it wasn't
written as a textbook and not sold as a
text but most of the sales i con i think
come
through you know in bookstores or maybe
amazon.com who knows and
people call me and say
i just bought six copies of your book to
send to to my grandmother in oklahoma
city and my brother-in-law
and what happens is people
it's easy to read
you know it's it's uh it's not academic
it's this is what people tell me again
and again uh you know they say it's it's
it's readable
and uh
and it's exciting and you may remember
that in the film goodwill hunting i
don't know if you saw the movie goodwill
hunting but in the film goodwill hunting
the character will hunting played by
matt damon at one point there's this
moment
in the movie where he's talking to robin
williams who's his sort of therapist
and he's in his office and he
he said what are you reading
he says if you want to read a real good
history book he says read the people's
history of the united states
well this is a surprise
to people who went to see the movie and
here's a movie that recommends a book
that doesn't happen too often in my hand
is the audio version
of your book read by matt damon right
was that your idea or his
neither
it was harper
collins
audio department they decided that it
would be good to have a people's history
on tape because it's too big a book you
know you'd need too many too many tapes
but they
selected about six hours
and then they approached matt damon
uh i didn't want to approach him because
i thought no he's too busy you know he's
making one film after another
and
they approached matt damon and of course
he's a great fan of my book
uh he and ben affleck is his friend both
great fans of my book
and uh and he agreed to do it so he
spent two days
taping which
i didn't really want him to do didn't
ask him to do but he it was just uh
you know an act of
friendship and
is he politically attuned to me is he on
the same side
i think he is yeah you know uh
well let's put this way yeah i mean he
knows the book very well
at the age of 10 his mother
i must tell you this i've known matt
damon since he was
i know five years old
uh he he his mother was a single mother
raising two boys they were our next-door
neighbors
his mother is a very in boston very good
friend
and when he was 10 years old she gave
matt my book
and he read it and then when he was in
high school his high school teacher in
cambridge read
used the book in class
ben affleck also was going to that same
school
he read the book so they both became
fans of the book and yeah and i think
they're attuned to the point of view
of the book
and you could tell this if you s
when you see the film goodwill hunting
there's a a great moment
even better than the moment in which he
recommends my book
a great moment in which this sort of
genius working-class kid who sweeps the
floors at mit is
approached because he's been discovered
as this mathematical genius and
everybody wants to hire him and the
national security agency wants to hire
mma
and he's being interviewed by the admin
and
and
he says to him oh he says national
security agency
he says i get it he says i would work
for you
and help you
break a code or something which would
enable you to bomb a peasant village in
a third world country
and then the bombing wouldn't do the
trick so he'd send over troops and
they'd send over some of my friends from
southie
south boston to fight
and they would come back you know maybe
wounded and then they would look for
jobs and they would find that the
company they worked for here
had moved to this third world country
which was bombed as a and he delivers
that very very fast
but it's a very
an unusually radical statement to make
in a movie about american foreign policy
on page 408 and i don't want to drone on
here but it seemed like this page
kind of summarized the way you feel
about
a lot of our involvements over the years
foreign intervention let me read just a
little bit about it and i'll
try not to go too far
for the united states to step forward as
a defender of helpless countries matched
its image in american high school
history books but not its record in
world affairs
it had opposed the haitian revolution
for independence from france at the
start of the 19th century it had
instituted a war with mexico and taken
half the country it had pretended to
help cuba win freedom from spain and
then planted itself in cuba with a
military base investments and rights of
intervention it had seized hawaii puerto
rico guam and fought a brutal war to
subjugate the filipinos it had opened
japan to its trade with gunboats and
threats it declared an open door policy
in china as a means of assuring the
united states would have opportunities
equal to other imperial powers in
exploiting china it had sent troops to
pay king with other nations to assert
western supremacy in china and kept them
from
kept them for over 30 years there's a
lot more in here about colombia and
haiti and nicaragua
is this country
this sounds like i'm
i'm
arguing with you but has this country
done anything right
um
well yeah
i'm sure we've done some
right things
um
you know when we have given economic aid
to countries uh
we have done right right you know from
time to time we will help out when you
know if there's a
you know if there's an earthquake or a
famine yeah we've done some right things
and
but in the main
and
i mean i understand that when you read
that litany of
offenses against other countries
it's kind of shocking
because we're all brought up to be proud
of our country and and its policies and
to think of us as the good guys in the
world and helping people in the world
but the fact is that we
have behaved
in the world and i'm not trying to
single out the united states we are the
you know evil no
uh
great powers
historically
have tried to spread their power all
over the world i mean the last 500 years
have been years in which one empire
after another has tried to dominate
the countries all over the world you
know the dutch empire and the spanish
and portuguese empire and the and the
french and german and british empire
and i mean all of them and the united
states came late upon the scene became
the greatest empire of all
so no the record of the united states
and dealing with other places in the
world you know it's just not a pleasant
one where would you go to get better
treatment for blacks better treatment
for women
better treatment for native americans in
the world if you had to pick a country
oh well of course other countries don't
have native american
pro you know the way that we do but
let's put it in basically minorities
yeah but but put this way where would i
go to have a
a country that
has more humane policy
uh
towards let's say it's poor people and
so on i guess the scandinavian countries
are are good models maybe new zealand is
another there are you know there are
at least 15 industrialized countries
where they take better care of their
children than we do
you know that where the infant mortality
rate is a much better one than us there
are countries that have universal health
care
and
and uh
and they're
the countries where if you're unemployed
you still will get enough money in
unemployment insurance so that you can
live and you can retire at an earlier
age in other words there are countries
that that
that have
social programs
that don't require them to have a great
percentage of the population in poverty
i mean we have 40 million people in this
country living at the at the edge of
poverty and we have the thing is we have
the least excuse for it because we are
the richest country in the world why do
you think we've not done better
well i think we haven't done better
because the motive
that drives our economic system
is not a motive of human need it's a
motive of
of corporate profit
and uh
and what we have done for people when we
have done it when we've passed and we
you asked have we done good things yeah
we've passed in the 1930s we passed
social security and unemployment
insurance and
you know housing subsidies
and and in the 1960s medicare
and medicaid and and um
but when these things happen they
usually happen as a result of some kind
of pressure from outside it didn't come
the system itself
doesn't
normally and instinctively do things
for the least privileged
instinctively it does things for the for
for the wealthy and it takes it takes
well what happened in the 30s is we had
great movements a labor movement in the
30s and and
[Music]
all sorts of turmoil all over the
country which i think had an
effect on roosevelt and congress and
passing legislation in the 60s again we
had
great movements of the 60s and riots of
black people in the cities and and
and i think lyndon johnson responded to
that with medicare and medicaid and a
war on poverty which was you know not
really fulfilled
so
it will
it would take a
an economic system i'm talking about
something very radically different that
isn't motivated by corporate profit that
where the motivation is how can we use
the wealth of our society
to
make sure that nobody no kid goes hungry
nobody is without a decent home
nobody who wants to work is without a
job nobody is without medical care
we have the wealth to do it i mean
that's the shame of it you know let me
read on page 650 a statement and get you
to
elaborate on it there is evidence of
growing this satisfaction among the
guards
i suppose by the guards
i i meant that
the
the great american middle class
which benefits somewhat you know we're
not the very poor
uh
and i call us the guards because we're
you know we're sort of in between the
the people who run the country and the
the corporate rich and and the and the
the underclass
and we were the great middle class and
we were the professionals and we're the
teachers and the doctors and and the
small business people and uh
and what i say i suppose
half in hope and half in prophecy
because after all who can predict what
will happen but i sort of say half and
hope that
the only hope there is for serious
change in this country is if people in
the middle class begin to feel
that something is wrong that even though
we are doing fairly well
that somehow we
we're uneasy in a country
where there are too many people who
don't enjoy the benefits
you know that
we in the middle class and certainly the
people in the upper class enjoy
and it seems to me that therefore the
people in the middle class looking
around at the amount of violence in a
society
uh well and we know we've seen that you
know incredible violence in this society
much more than in any other
industrialized country i mean the number
of murders that take place in this
country compared to the number of
murders that take place in england or
scandinavia it's shocking
uh the violence the
number of people in prison in this
country close to two million people in
prison now there's a sign of sickness in
in a society when you have to put two
million people probably more than
perhaps any other country in the world
in prison
and seems to me that
the middle class the guards looking at a
society where the middle class has to be
careful about muggings and crime and
where people in new york who are well
off have to put six locks on their door
and where such a large portion of the
population
is
really
being
turned into less than human
by being sent to prison and then come
out of prison worse than before
it seems to me the middle class must
be getting uneasy about that
i hope they are
and and thinking that
we even though we're doing well we the
guards
um
we don't want to live in a society that
doesn't
distribute the benefits of society more
humanely
than is now done has there been a
politician in your lifetime in this
country who you consider to be caring
caring about the little people
well
and i don't mean that
important people i mean the people who
don't have anything sure
caring
well the problem is that even if
somebody who is caring
you know and they are courageous or done
anything well roosevelt you know
roosevelt was certainly more caring and
more courageous probably prodded by his
wife
eleanor i think if you call her a
politician maybe she was a politics
she's a politician who was definitely a
caring person you know she had worked
with the poor as you know as a social
worker
in new york and she and and she had a
feeling about black people in this
country and racism
and she certainly was a humane
compassionate yes political figure and i
think she had an effect on her husband
i haven't seen too much of that
and even where even where a political
figure has some humane feelings there is
something about the process of going
through you know the up the political
ladder
and getting into the white house and
being surrounded by the military and the
corporate and the people who contributed
money there's something about that that
begins to sap whatever humanitarian
energy you started with here is the book
and it's in a new printing
first came out in 1980 but updated to
the clinton administration of people's
history of the united states 1492 to
present our guest has been howard zinn
thank you thank you very much
um
[Music]
for a transcript of this book notes call
1-800-777-text
for a video copy call 1 800 c span 98 to
read the first chapter of many books
featured on book notes visit us on the
world wide web at booknotes.org
week on booknotes our guest is luang
author of